thank you
[Music]
so did you guys hear what about the
magic the Gathering card that just sold
for [__] two million dollars two
million did you guys ever get into magic
my sister did oh really yeah you think
it's that's crazy because she's hot yeah
no way she's into that no [__] way
I'm not I'm not gonna believe you said
it was like a one of one is it actually
like there's only one was it Lord of the
Rings right so Wizards of the Coast
they're behind Magic the Gathering
they're also behind the Pokemon cards
right so they printed
um doing a tie-in with Lord of the Rings
they printed a one-of-one card which is
like the one ring which is kind of a
sick marketing move and it it sold a
[__] ton of boosters dude which is like
when people are buying magic cards
they're buying boosters oh man I'm just
so glad it went to a person that
actually knows the value exactly just
threw them away it could be some grandma
could have got it for some little ass
kid who doesn't even like that you never
know so this is what it looks like this
is 2.5 million dollars on a [__]
piece oh my God so if you get that card
in Magic the Gathering does that mean
you just beat everybody or you're like
the ultimate card
so they released us how long ago this
was released uh I want to say a year and
a half ago oh so they're still printing
new cards oh yeah Magic's still going
strong oh yeah yeah there's a there's a
place I drive by a place all the time
and they're always filled up
bro they play that [__] wait there's a
there's a place that you could go in and
Bully the whole store you know what they
seem like nice folks I love that place
oh is that like the place like um like
at the park where people can play chess
yeah they're doing that they're playing
Magic they're playing all kinds of like
it's like Games Workshop but like yeah
yeah they play that yeah yeah yeah is it
Outdoors that's funny the person who
introduced me to magic cards was a gang
member yeah really some of the most
hardcore guys I know play Magic the
Gathering yeah who are like little
gangsters and [__] so the most became
fire the most expensive card in together
in history it's called Black Lotus
right wow which sold for 450 000 most
recently oh so that's how [__] crazy
this is because Black Lotus isn't a one
of one black lotus is like it's rare
it's the rarest Magic the Gathering card
but this is a one of one this cat pulls
it
there's a video of him in post Malone
and like you can like see post Malone
like looks at it he's like yeah I'll
take it and that means 2.5 million in
this guy's bank account and the guy
starts crying wow they agree on that
price dude 2.5
the taxes because you're [__] losing
like at least a Mill and that's what and
social media did and they just they're
destroying post Malone because the taxes
is just gonna destroy this guy this guy
he won't be able to afford taxes that's
what happened to Mr Beast Mr Beast gives
away [__] and the Mr Beast is actually a
piece of [__] because all these people
are gonna get attacked I know that was a
stupid I love that [__] uh yeah no but
this card 2.5 million dollars
one of one
guy sells it
and then but but the craziest thing
right nobody knew who the [__] this guy
was so there's a video of him opening he
like opens the card and then he holds it
up right and you can see his [__]
handshake if he did unboxing boxing
right he's holding it hand shaking like
this but nobody had known who the guy
who the guy was until now because he
posted this video in post Malone people
like me are worried about this cat
because now we all know he's got 2.5
million dollars and like what's gonna
happen so he posted a video of him it's
like being a lot of winners yeah oh no
post Malone for the first time that's
kind of cool you want to record it too
yeah but people knew that the card had
got because the video but they never
knew who it was until now
so he posted a video of I found it
hopefully you stay safe huh dude you
know how many smeagles are gonna be
hunting here
is he though is it harder to keep the
fact that you won the lotto a secret or
is it harder to keep the fact that you
got this card a secret in a community
that that's all you guys [__] care
about oh [__] yes probably this you
probably this one I think this one yeah
because now you just became part of like
magic history yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
you're Lord yeah exactly like but
Lottery it's like I don't know [__]
Sarah gugensburg I don't know what the
[__] is every [__] made dude it's
just a different thing
a little bit better too because like
this you have to make him help like to
sell it but what about post Malone
though like isn't he a Target now
I mean he's but he's been protected the
whole time yeah
oh I didn't know I thought our like big
time singers just fight their own fights
of a man almost
but yeah dude the fact that this dude
now has 2.5 mil and I mean hopefully his
Social Circle is healthy enough to still
treat him the same
so other people were pulling the the one
ring right because it wasn't a
one-of-one but this is the the one of
one oh okay yeah so that's why it's like
such a big deal yeah it's like getting a
Venom but then no yours is a holographic
silver limited edition one of one Venom
yeah he's got the golden ticket but it's
not the same you don't have the 101.
he's got the golden ticket yeah damn oh
I hope this guy gets a financial advisor
immediately well he's a nerd so he
probably is gonna manage his money right
yo he just spends it all on other magic
cards so maybe I'll get another ring
maybe I'll get another one of them
have you ever won like anything like
[__] not like that I did pull well I did
pay
um ten dollars in quarters and I
remember pissing off this guy to card
store
because when I played Game Boy I
remember playing Pokemons and I remember
um Bulbasaur was my favorite Pokemons so
I was like I'm gonna go buy the Venusaur
first edition it's 10 bucks they're a
plant type game I don't give a [__] yeah
but it's 10 bucks so then I can break
and I only want to do it so I could dunk
on my little brother's be like you don't
have the first edition [__] you guys
that's all I wanted to do it for and so
I went and I had brought a quarter jar
and I [__] counted and I'm gonna
count on this guy's like [__] me that
card by the way right now is worth like
[__] 20 G's holy I know because my
it's my mom's a hoarder it's probably
dead cats on top of it what if you do
find it though what if you go and clean
up and then like it just pops out of
nowhere for that but is it in the right
condition oh because there might be bird
[__] otherwise you're my dumb [__] Uncle
Mark who thinks that every comic book
that you have
every comic book they have is the the
amount that it says in the manual at the
highest mint price no Uncle Mark that's
why you're [__] right that's why you
breathe with your South right that's why
nobody wants to hire you to do anything
yeah right you can't even get a job
[__] being a greeter at a store yeah
because you would complain he would
complain he's not a good agreed because
he's like why'd you want to come into
Walmart Uncle Mark Walmart the [__] you
doing here go down the street and get
something even better why are you here
sell these things at the gas station way
cheaper
welcome to Walmart that's all you have
to say advertising other places dude I
was at I was on my on the phone with my
mom recently because like you know my
grandma just died so we're trying to
figure out what to do with the estate
and stuff like that
and I was like I was like well you know
don't let the house be like the comic
books because Uncle Mark's so [__]
stupid and then my mom's like you're on
speakerphone and I was like Uncle Mark
you should probably hear this too
because the house is like water damage
all this [__] don't think that just
because on Zillow it says this price
bro are you gonna uh does your grandma
have a bunch of cool she like gonna go
there just to see if like what you can
take I already got all of them
no honestly when my Grandpa died the
coolest thing that they ever gave me was
my grandpa's Marine Corps cufflinks
that's cool
you carry it with you
I want to go back to my grandparents
house and get all their old pictures I
don't think anyone else in the family
cares about them and I want to like get
them out all scanned I'm the only one
that has old pictures
Marine Corps cufflinks
you've seen those I'm sure but yeah no
um you wore those at the Marine Corps
ball when he like yeah graduated and
[__]
yeah so that was like that's like the
air the only heirloom I really have is
that are you guys gonna I can get it now
Steve
I think I might make some [__] up
you might do one yeah I'll make a bullsh
I'll make some [__]
I'll send all [__] I don't know maybe
I'll heirloom this
what are you gonna do and get them like
priced out somewhere I looked into that
and I I think last time I mentioned that
a JK fan was like hey I like I I do uh
or he's connected to like some grater I
do a lot of thieving in this but I feel
like let's get jacked yeah
I'm gonna be super [__] expensive I
think they're gonna be oh they've gone
down some like they were Sky High right
after Colby had passed they were like
insane but then now I think plus like I
think as perfect as each card does look
because I never took them out I'm sure
they're still like a eight or seven yeah
I'm sure you get nine it's [__] like
positive climate controlled room damn
dude yeah the way that grade is a scam
yeah exactly so there's that too there's
no place to get it can you hit me up
I'll bring my cards too much huh what do
you got I have a bunch of basketball
cards like rookie Jordans yeah rookie
Jordan Sean Kim [__] like that whole
era I have a bunch of them Grant Hill I
have a bunch of dude I have a bunch of
Pokemon cards that I turned out to be
stickers
oh no but I have a whole binder full of
Pokemon cards but I I try to look it up
myself and I'm like
I'm just gonna give it to a guy to see I
should just give this to some kid yeah I
have like Bruce Lee cards I don't know
what those are dude Bruce Lee Carr yeah
I have no idea Kareem Abdul-Jabbar is on
one of them Game of Death probably
worthless you should give it to me I
don't know if they are worth anything
you know what Jordan came back for a
brief moment and it was number 45 I even
have a card 45 on it too what the wizard
I don't know for just that brief moment
when he came back he didn't want to be
23. he was 45 he's 45 I have a 45 card
too two weeks yeah yeah I went back to
23.
you're the worst you're not even
bragging about it you're like [__]
throwing it away yeah you should be brag
about it try it again take it from the
top yeah oh yeah
I got lots of basketball cards guys
we're better I'm jealous of people that
wow there were a bunch of people in my
school when I was a kid that managed to
get the Jordan baseball card that's cool
they were all laughing about it Joe you
have one I had one dude yeah and then
you didn't think it was anything right I
thought it was fine rookie binder got
stolen dude oh it's worth a lot I talk
too much about it uh yeah yeah remember
you told me that at your house you
[__] went in there
Sean Camp rookie I had Jordan rookies I
was a [__] idiot yeah he let him in
dude I was like this whole binder
rookies and then some kids just like
that's a good idea I don't think it
never saw him again you remember his
name
I thought you would remember that I
thought you were about revenge Steve I'm
starting to think you're [__] I don't
want to get into a legal situation Nick
isn't that crazy to think that that your
card could have ended up in some glass
with a 9.5 in some guy's graded
collection isn't that crazy it's gross
it's disgusting it's changed over the
years isn't that crazy who plays
basketball cards you can't I took it out
of the [__] pack and I put it right
in the binder yeah yeah they were Gucci
yeah right take them out that's it you
don't like take them out and look at
them and show you that's the worst thing
about Pokemon cards you
yeah I played it one time and I was like
I'm bad at this game and I just put them
in the binder locked them up where's the
binder is that my house I just found it
the other day and I was looking through
it again and I was like this is a
[__] sticker I know it and I'm right
there
Pickers are the best cards or something
he's like this is a printed picture of a
Pokemon card
it's not even in color that twist is
funny it's black and white I'm an idiot
that twist and stickers are more
valuable because what if it's like the
limited edition sticker card he goes
what's this [__] [__] you know
what about taking them all off it's it's
the stickers that you would get in a
vending machine I know though like the
homies ones
in yeah
it's Japanese and it's like crazy
holographic and I looked I pulled it out
I was like this can't be worth anything
bro and I peeled it
that might be the [__] Tokyo
exclusive so I took the stickers off and
I put it all over my house next I have a
picture of a Charizard from a Blackberry
a 2000
dude I'd be dying without a high depth
that'd be hell funny post Malone after
he shows that he got the magic cards on
now if only I could find those Pokemon
stickers those holographic stickers
nobody has them
please